the major objectives of today's
Symposium are to identify and share some
great case studies of actual machine
learning applications in areas around
energy and the environment we wanted to
bring stakeholders together to really
share what their major gaps and
challenges are so that we can look for
those synergies and opportunities to
work together is to really think about
how can we benefit from the expertise in
the room to benefit from the expertise
across the country to actually develop
some new initiatives and new and
Innovative approaches for Canada we're
meeting today building off of a report
that several of us wrote for the global
partnership and AI which is a
multi-government initiative and in that
report we provided recommendations for
how governments can act to enable AI in
the pursuit of climate action in this
Symposium we're trying to take those
insights and situate them within a
Canadian context and work out how the
Canadian governmental entities can work
better to enable this kind of work
moving forward there is huge diversity
in the room with respect to to the
expertise and the perspectives not just
the geographic diversity and the
sectoral diversity but you know we have
government researchers and government
policy makers we have Venture
capitalists in the room we have lots of
academic researchers it's exciting to
see how people are connecting with each
other how they are identifying they've
heard something earlier in the day that
really struck their interest in their
curiosity and now they're catching out
somebody across the room and identifying
them and introducing themselves and
saying I'm interested in what you said
here's what I'm working on I came to
learn but also to share some of the
perspectives that I experienced as a
scientist so it's really a fantastic
space to be in regardless if you are in
Academia or in industry and government
to start answering those questions AI is
a multi-purpose set of Technologies and
there are many ways that it can help
address climate change both reducing
greenhouse gas emissions and helping
Society adapt to the effects of climate
change we also see roles for government
in helping Bridge research to deployment
oftentimes work gets stranded at the
research stage and isn't really
connected with stakeholders who can
ensure that it has the impact that it
needs to have we've seen a lot of
synergy in the ideas that people are
raising and some of them seem like they
should be simple problems to solve but
when we Dig Down deeply into them I
think they're going to be quite
complicated in Canada I have found that
we have the expertise we have the
natural resources we have the technology
we have the ecosystem I think that we
are doing a fantastic job on integrating
each of them but I really think that we
can continue to converge to do these
fantastic merging and to establish
ourselves as a national leader in these
areas there's a lot of drive and
enthusiasm that I see in the audience
and I look forward to seeing that
translated into action but there's a lot
that we need to do
[Music]